if I kiss you that doesn't make me gay I
just did a gay thing for a second and if
I make a racist joke or say a a bad word
I don't mean that thing I just did it
for a second you see what I'm saying but
how many gay things do you have to do
before you become gay I think it's all
up here it's like being a woman I
identity you identity straight yeah yeah
because the second is a it's just a
physical act right actually wanting to
suck it that's when you're gay
interesting blow it you could blow me
right now and I won't call you gay I
promise
wait are we on yeah sure oh geez I
didn't know that let's say that we're on
uh Mark Norman hey comedy I didn't know
if I was gonna trash those other Comics
you just mentioned so I had to make sure
um good to be here thanks man new studio
uh yeah different we're in a new place I
like this place it's very very cool yeah
it is it's kind of like what I imagine
the inside of a dildo looks like hey
this is the flashlight right here yeah
ribbed for your pleasure
smells weird dude it's a little sticky
but yeah um so you're seeing Tom Segura
at some point I think while you're in
town he's just finished a 300-day tour
what do people who have never been on
tour that look at comedians that are
traveling the world and think oh that's
cool yeah that'd be good to do what do
they not know about what tour life's
actually like well there's there's a
couple different kind there's the and
the two extremes would be sagora and
Bert which and their friends they're yin
and yang and uh
Bert is a drunk fat guy who's partying
where Segura has a trainer every morning
at 8am he doesn't really drink he eats
well he's uh playing the piano he's
writing so that's really the tour of
life you know just which one are you on
that spectrum and I I'm more towards
Bert and I'm worried because I'm gonna
die but that's really that's really what
it is touring is grueling and it looks
fun we show you Instagram of us on a jet
or or at the big arena with the
chandelier and the the curtains but it's
a lot of get up what are we doing today
oh we got to go to the airport oh the
airport's in a different language we got
to figure this out it's it's a lot of
logistics and that part sucks
is that it's fun yeah I I don't know I
guess the reality from the outside is
tons of travel lots of packing and
unpacking yes being in and out of hotels
nightmare it's all a blur it's like that
montage and Fight Club where he's just
going from place to place and you're
like who am I where am I what's going on
uh I gotta write a new joke is that joke
so you're on the flight any moment you
have you're like all right I gotta rest
and think about my ACT yeah I I guess um
Ryan long was talking about this as well
the the reality of tour life is so
different to what people sort of
idealize oh yeah and what I think most
guys are doing at the moment is these
little weekends right you just jump out
spend a weekend two nights three nights
if you can and then you come back and
he's like I kind of have a life but then
I don't have a life and then I yes have
a life and I don't but you're going to
Australia I'm going straight over a
month but those weekends are that's
ideal because you get to escape you hate
your girlfriend you hate your husband
you hate your wife you hate your
apartment you hate your city I live in
New York and says hobos and and [__] on
the street and Subways so then you get
to go to Denver and you're like oh I
smoke weed I'll go get a hike I'll do
shows and then I'll come back so it's
perfect it's like a built-in marriage
saver have you heard of digital
blackface oh wait a minute is that where
you act black online kind of yeah so
this is from CNN if you're white and
you've posted a gif or a meme of a black
person to express a strong emotion you
may be guilty of wearing digital
blackface right to John Blake maybe you
shared that viral video of Kimberly
Sweet Brown Wilkins telling a reporter
after narrowly escaping an apartment
fire ain't nobody got time for that
you posted that Meme of supermodel Tyra
Banks exploding in anger on America's
Next Top Model if you're black and
you've shared such online images you get
a pass but if you're white you may have
inadvertently perpetuated one of the
most Insidious forms of contemporary
racism you may be wearing digital
blackface simply put digital blackface
is 21st century
Minstrel C Ministry
wow I mean I thought I was being
inclusive by adding some black people in
my memes and my gifts isn't that diverse
I'm diversifying my gifts appropriating
I guess so jeez I asked Jordan Peterson
what uh color Emoji he uses and he said
black oh really that's funny you can't
get in trouble I mean we're all using
the eggplant that's black is it oh did
you speak based on size size and you
know it's a dark shade of purple but you
know Moulin Yan is what Italians call
black people and that means eggplant
that's the uh that's the N word for
Italians you're kidding me yes
like these bouillon's over here stole
our truck
and it means eggplant it means eggplant
in Italian but that's their N word wow
oh yeah Italians don't give a [__] they
don't give a [__] and it sounds cool it
just sounds pretty
less offensive than hard-arring your way
through some yeah like racial tirade
exactly they also call uh [__]
people [__] no I'm just kidding but
um that would be I'm sure they got a
cool word for that too
but yeah digital blackface man you got
to be careful out there well they know
number one threat to America's white
supremacy according to our presidents so
uh that's an interesting one I see I
like this stuff because it just shows
that we're not that racist if we have to
look this far to find racism that's a
good sign that maybe we're not as racist
so I learned about this idea called
concept creep which you'll probably be
familiar with but the way that it's sort
of come across or being used I guess in
um the modern world is is super super
interesting because let's say that
there's a a bar of racism that needs to
be oh there is a a demand for racism
that's called a biker bar all right
sorry ah there's a demand for racism
that needs to be met and if racism isn't
getting bigger what you need to do is
expand the definition of it in order to
maintain the supply perfect yeah so
concept creep is when the demand for
racism outstrips the supply of racism
yeah you need to continually make more
and more things racist to keep that
level high wow see I love when these
these smart people come up with terms
because it just solidifies it all right
there it's succinctly explains it well
if you think about there are a number of
people who's basically entire careers
you know the CNN reporter they need to
write an article right John Blake needs
to write an article for CNN for today
God what am I going to write about is uh
well you're the racism guy like yeah
specialize in racism right you've got to
go get out there find yourself some
digital blackface and that's now the
thing but yeah I think looking at
fascinating looking at uh the increased
um dilution of what different types of
bigotisms and phobias and whatevers the
reason for that is that there is a lack
of Supply yes still an amount of demand
it's kind of like uh crackheads well
like you start out with a good good
solid crack rock and then eventually
like maybe I mix baking soda and a
frog's ass and like uh peroxide I'll get
high and it's not actually drugs anymore
but you just you need to open it up a
little more to get high because you
can't get the crack so you're saying
modern day racism is like poor quality
drugs yeah it's stepped on right you
know it's been you've got a baby like I
want this pure racism yeah what is the
cure racism you know like good
old-fashioned Colombian yes from The
Source Jim Crow that was pure cut
cocaine you know Jim Crow KKK the the
what do you call the hoses with the dogs
civil rights stuff that was that was
pure cut and now we're stepping on it
with [__] babies in the blackface
yeah exactly did Jack Black face is baby
powder for that right I sent you earlier
on a video about Dove yeah that was
great so for the people that haven't
seen it Dove is on a mission to
challenge and change female
representation in video games and help
make gaming a positive space for women
and girls so they've created this video
of like superhero girl superhero and
they she slays this this evil Baddie and
then she gets back into the changing
room and takes her armor off and gains
80 pounds yeah that was odd immediately
and then like sits down puts her hands
behind about and realizes I don't need
to wear the armor that is holding me in
and then she goes out and like keeps on
fighting but now she's 80 pounds bigger
yeah
um
female characters in games do not
accurately represent the diverse Gamers
of the world and are often heavily
sexualized and created within narrow
unrealistic beauty standards 74 of girls
feel unrepresented in video games
um I'm looking forward to the Call of
Duty lizzo skin dropping I want to
unlock I want to unlock lizzo too big of
a target a terrorist it's too easy but
here's why with a couple things I love
the idea of the animator being like the
director's like we need her fatter so
he's like oh [__] all right so he has to
make her bigger but also
I get it look it's all I'm all about
helping women and having them being
represented but aren't we
going it's it's getting hacky now like
Miller Lite Bud Light all the uh
Starbucks had a big commercial with the
Trans and you're like well now it's just
hacked the whole thing with the
marketing and and uh stuff like this
like this kind of art you gotta go a new
way isn't that the whole point of uh
being original like
when they Zig you zag and they're all
zagging everybody's going in the same
direction yeah so I'm like to me it's
not even about the the woke [__] or
whatever you want to call it it's like
you're just being unoriginal now it's
boring it's boring I think the main
concern that people unpredictable it's
kind of the same as the like Supply
demand problem for racism which is it
doesn't seem genuine yes it's forced
yeah completely forced completely uh
what do you call that uh
starts with a C contrived thank you you
nailed it [__] yeah wow Captain what's
happening together the periods are
singing That's menstrual cycle exactly
um
cycle of menstrually cycle
um so yeah I think it's just that people
don't believe that this is is this
actually coming from a place of genuine
sympathy or is this coming from what's
it called woke washing yeah yes Madison
Avenue yeah I learned uh what was the
[__] thing work washing is allowing
Brands to monetize virtue signaling it
conceals the less altruistic business
practices so Miller Lite and Bud Light
you know there's two good examples that
you brought up there
where are they getting their tin from is
anybody looking at the aluminum that
goes into the cans of course not like
looking at the production processes are
they meeting sanitation standards are
they doing all the rest of it and it's
like no but they gave Dylan Mulvaney six
a six-pack with her face on it that's
like enough to look over there look over
there you don't need to look over here
yes yes and I think with the dove maybe
actually does feel a little bit like
um
a company that for a long time has been
fighting for different beauty standards
they've done with skin that's true like
trying to get representation for
different girls but if you're gonna
fight the good fight it doesn't feel
like video games are the place that
girls are looking yeah find their
representation exactly and they there
was no soap in that commercial there was
not one bar of soap not a lotion nothing
yeah exactly it was just video gaming
and I'm like I don't know it's also
weird that we have to shoehorn women
sure there are women Gamers I'm sure but
like it doesn't feel like that's their
their big uh demo is these these fat
ladies like like advertise on uh
Vanderpump Rules like every lady I know
my wife included has like six girls over
they're all watching it I walk in
they're like shh
exactly exactly but she's not there
which is also probably why it's doing
well you know it goes back to the Barbie
it's like Barbie's unrealistic and I'm
like yeah yeah but who wants a realistic
toy you know but women think they're
gonna think they have to look like that
I'm like
maybe they want to look like that or
maybe you know uh that's that's okay if
you wanna like I every superhero I had
was jacked I don't want a fat superhero
well I'm not jacked someone so I put
this out on Twitter earlier on and
someone replied and said
um
they can't wait for a version of Kratos
you know from God of War are you
familiar with that guy it's like just
like a jacked God God figure type guy
can't wait for uh skinny fat Kratos or
um Solid Snake right uh to be creeping
around but he's lost a foot you to
diabetes
I don't know just there seems to me if
you need if you're so narcissistic that
you need direct representation yeah in
your avatar in a computer game there are
bigger problems than Simply Having a
fuller figured Avatar are going to be
able to fix yes completely and
it's just human nature we like to look
at attractive things I mean every
president who won has been taller every
I think maybe except for one but it's
always a taller guy who wins full head
of hair helps yeah yeah I mean it's it's
in men too like we we want our men
looking the right way as well what was
that was it Nixon did he do some famous
uh debate yes he was one of them was
sweaty and the other one wasn't sweaty
he did one on radio and one against
Kennedy because she couldn't see how
good-looking Kennedy was and then when
they were at TV aired it Kennedy won
that pretty privilege man yeah I don't
know I I think it's just
it's such a shame that you have
conversations that get captured by
like there are much longer levers than
trying to fix yes whether or not girls
are being misrepresented in video games
exactly and uh let's talk to the ladies
see what they think also it just first
of all It Feels So forced but oh I
forgot my point you said something say
it say what you said again maybe it'll
jog it that it oh I got it back thank
you that's all I needed was your sweet
sweet in uh English voice so oh I lost
it again say it again start talking
oh I got it
I got is real but uh you mentioned the
the tin can where's that coming from and
then like here's a perfect example
Kaepernick everybody's blowing
Kaepernick he's kneeling he hates police
I get it
Nike the biggest example of all
sweatshops you know we need the Asian
fingers to make the shoes and all that
and you can Overlook that because you're
looking at the guy with the afro who's
got the fist up and you go hey I'm a
good person but when you say to people
well what about the Sweatshop people
they go ah and you're like no no you're
not allowed to go ahead me with the
Sweatshop and like Kaepernick you have
to if you're such a morally good person
and Superior correct you have to agree
to both but they just they just shut one
out and that's where I get pissed well
hypocrisy is just like the perfect
tool that people want to point out on
the internet right because For the First
Time Ever we have this
um locked in stone history of every
single thing that we've said precisely
as we said it at the times that we said
it and it allows you to say well hang on
you you're making this point now but I
can see that that's not exactly aligned
with what you used to say previously
right so one of my smart Friends the one
that taught me about concept creep he
also taught me that in the modern world
our opinions and our Deeds have never
been further apart in the past any
opinion and any deed would have ended up
being stress tested at some point if you
say that you're a good person and 20 000
years ago around the campfire and yet
every time you go out hunting you don't
bring back meat for everybody else you
just bring it for your family eventually
someone's gonna go well come on you keep
you keep saying you're a good person
right whereas on Twitter no one ever
actually ends up scrutinizing the way
that you show up in the real world you
can be the most empathetic Pro female
person in the world and you go home beat
your wife yes and nobody knows for the
most part nobody knows and then when
people get rumbled for it that's why it
feels so satisfying to us yes I think
that it's because we have this sense
that a lot of the people who push
virtual real virtual beauty or push
digital blackface is something that
should genuinely be cared about are just
doing performative empathy I don't think
that we believe that it's true
completely right but the pro come with
the the empathy is like when you're on
the other side of it when like let's say
you're Ellen who you know big and her
thing is like well you said because she
was the happy Dancy nice lady and then
when we found out she was a Coos
everybody flipped on her because she was
performing uh but the problem is Ellen
could be like well I donate a million
dollars a charity I do all this I helped
the homeless I help old people but we
just know about the thing yes so you
don't get that redeeming part and we
love Sam Harris had a great point he
said if if the first time you hear about
somebody is when they've done something
wrong maybe don't jump to hate them
that's the first thing you've heard
about them
what about all the other good [__] they
did but we don't care about that we just
go oh uh Michael J fox said [__] in 88
I've never heard of this guy like if
you're some young person I've never
heard of Michael J fox I hate him now
and you're like you hate him now because
you heard one thing about him on the in
a headline but you just
you totally disregard his whole other
life it's crazy
it's a shame that we
sort of jump to conclusions so quickly
and this difference between opinions and
deeds the fact that you're able to
behave in one way and say a different
thing and people will care about what
you say more than what you do because
yeah you do is never seen exactly but it
also means that when you do try and
actually put some empathy across that
gets scrutinized too oh well maybe
you're just doing this because no I
genuinely care I care about this
movement or I care about this group of
people This Is Me Being Earnest or
vulnerable or open and not for some
perverse reason I'm doing this because I
actually care about a thing yeah and
immediately people use the same uh idea
the methodology the skepticism they have
about all the other [__] from all of the
other people that have been doing the
concept creep Supply demand [__] and
then they apply to you and you go well
I'd like and I think that
disincentivizes people completely
genuine completely altruism as well I
agree yeah it's it's a it's a tough time
makes people just not want to do
anything and just hang back so they
don't get yelled at you seem to be quite
a positive person generally yeah yeah I
think so how do you avoid getting drawn
into cynicism and there is this sort of
culture of negativity and and sexism on
the internet what's your prophylactic
against that what do you what condom are
you wearing well I hear the uh the old
post and ghost I'm a big on that and uh
my friend he works with Louis CK a lot
so he gets a lot of hate you know so he
just started blocking everybody and he's
like I don't even hear them anymore like
anybody who says one thing I just start
blocking him on Twitter or whatever and
uh so it just eventually he kind of like
cleaned it out and I'm like that's
pretty good but you still have to go in
and read it to block it yep so I don't
want to do that so I just kind of I let
it go and I'm sure this fire is going on
all over and I just try to put out of my
mind and that protects your mental space
relatively while it seems relatively
well I mean I've definitely had my my
weeks of like sleepless nights I'm like
this guy said this uh it Taps into some
[__] up thought you had about yourself
and it validates all the evil thoughts
you have and then it just it just
mushroom clouds in your brain and you're
in the shower going uh maybe I am
attracted to kids you know or whatever
the [__] and I'm I'm not but uh you know
people can just get in your head and you
know when I was 15 I was like am I gay
Maybe I'm gay am I gay and I had this
friend who was super hot and ripped and
I blew up no but I had this friend he
was super hot I kept being like am I
attracted to him I don't know I don't
know and it's to say you can do that
with anything like am I racist what the
hell and I'm like hanging out with a
bunch of black guys last night at the
mothership and you're just like what if
I I'm not racist but you just your brain
can go in these [__] up places
especially mine mine could really turn
on me it's so funny that you can
question your own like sense of self
completely because of what somebody's
just
prodded or poked you in the direction of
at the right time and that's really what
Twitter is it's this weird little
prodding and uh Colin Quinn describes it
as you're giving yourself schizophrenia
because it's literally eight million
opinions and you're just absorbing all
of them and that's what schizophrenia is
just 800 voices going off all the time
and you're Outsourcing personal insults
from the internet yes yes exactly but
some some Harris said that um being on
Twitter is like the most malignant form
of telepathy ever that only allows you
into the worst of everybody else's
thoughts wow classic classic
wordsmithing from he's the king Mr
Harris he's the best I mean there's not
a lot of positivity it's not a lot of
like I had a great day today just had a
hell of a turkey sandwich and I got a
great my ass got eaten you don't really
see that on Twitter you know it's just
you know ah this guy's racist he's a
piece of [__] whatever yeah that's an
idea for a future tweet you can throw
that out talking about whatever it is
that you've eaten and then what when
you've been eaten yeah avoiding the
cynicism things it's a tough one man and
I really I'm really trying to sort of
slowly nudge myself away from it really
trying to rail against it yeah um just
seeing what happens if you do try and
give people a little bit more hope you
know Michael malice you familiar with
Mikey oh yeah smart guy yeah so he he
wrote this book about
um the
period from sort of
1920 1910 up to 1990 in Russia and it's
all about the the absolute Terrors of
Communism and famine and all sorts of
crazy [__]
his point was
we thought that this was the worst that
the world could ever ever get this is
how low things sank these are the
terrible stories of famine and prisoner
mistreatment and children and all this
sort of stuff and the good guys won so
his argument it was called the white
pill the book and the reason for that
was that he said
if you think that the evil people always
win here is the most Stark example of
the evil people losing oh thank God but
the problem is it took 90 years or
whatever you said that's the problem is
you want it to happen next week but it
it takes so long and then you know like
black people were marginalized and
oppressed and all this and now I feel
like they're doing doing well
uh but now it's kind of like [__] Whitey
so we're gonna be in that for a while
then that'll go away but it just it just
sucks when your your life and your
adulthood is like right in the middle of
the [__] part that's a really good point
I often you know
there's this really interesting study I
remember seeing ages ago that looked at
the difference if you were born in I
want to say 1920 or 1930 and if you were
born in 1920 you grew up during the
formative years when you needed
nutrition being the Great Depression
then by the time that the war came
around you were conscripted to go and
fight yes and then let's say that you've
survived both of those traumas you
finally came out and like died in the
70s or some [__] like that let's say
whereas if you were born in 1930 you've
got to you weren't conscripted you came
out the other side you got to live most
of your Glorias through swinging 60s 70s
psychedelic Revolution right you know
increased equality all this sort of
stuff and um yeah I do wonder sometimes
in retrospect what am I going to think
about the generation that I was a part
of totally throwing a pandemic throwing
911 throwing uh the George Floyd stuff
like it's a wild time
but you know the 60s were wild and MLK
got shot they went to the moon uh
Vietnam so there's always uh there's
always bad [__] but the problem is this
is new bad [__] with the internet this
is all
unprecedented yeah novel novel problems
yes yes so we're not only are we
figuring out how to deal with it we
don't know what the hell it is and it's
it's all new and kids are killing
themselves and girls are depressed and
you know they're addicted 60 of teenage
girls say that they have persistent or
regular feelings of hopelessness
unbelievable it's so sad and you know
like the 60s you mentioned growing up
then or in the 20s and in the 30s and
the depression and all that world war
one two I bet they were happier
you think I bet they were happier
because you had a goal it's like
depression gotta get bread gotta get
food gotta get some water now I'm in
World War One Gotta Stay Alive Gotta
Stay Alive now it's world you gotta stay
alive you know the the Air Raids rare
rare you know I think that was at least
somewhat we have a common enemy we got a
common goal to survive now it's just
like
this looming cloud of sadness and like
did I get enough clicks and is this
person gonna drag me online and you know
it's just it's this weird kind of
ungrabbable sadness whereas before it
was very like the Russians are gonna
shoot us or Hitler's bad or whatever I'm
being anxiety hey that's good yeah we're
in AAA and but it's the I totally get
the
um the directionlessness the fact that
you don't have a single call it an enemy
or a life goal or you know direction
that you're moving toward means that you
kind of just get distracted by
everything and I think a lot of people
have this sense that a lot of their
mental time in their sanity is taken up
worrying about things that probably
don't matter yes just the number of
cycles that your brain goes through per
day having thoughts that tomorrow you're
not going to be glad that you had yeah
who it was that says um uh the bizarre
thing about life is that it has to be
lived forward but only makes sense in
Reverse oh that's good when you think
about the fact that you know you look
back over the last five years of your
life Maybe
from 10 years ago until five years ago
you can kind of oh yeah well I
understand I was I was here and that's
why I was here and then this thing
happened and then that changed me and
then whatever and then you look at now
and you go what the [__] am I doing yeah
like why what why what what are all of
these different contributing elements
and am I doing it right am I doing it
right I might be doing it wrong yeah
should I be doing it should I even
change it exactly I know it's uh it's
tough because you know you know when you
get into a relationship and you're like
man I want to get out I hate this girl
she hates me all we do is fight and then
you break up and you're like I miss her
I love her so much the relationship was
perfect and I think we're gonna look
back on it like that like right now it's
like this looming what did you say
ambient anxiety ambient anxiety which
sucks and I it it's always in my brain
and I hate it and I can't shake it but I
think when I'm 80 I'm gonna look back
and go man the internet those are wild
time porn only fans uh Stormy Daniels
Rachel Zola we're gonna look back and go
wow that was [__] nuts because we're
not gonna remember all the ambience I'm
gonna be thinking about Stormy Daniels
on your 80. oh I like to jerk off to her
because I I know her it's fun to jerk
off someone who's on the news you know
you get to see the CNN story and then go
right there you can text us straight
away yeah yeah so uh it's it's a cookie
time but I think you gotta just press on
and my thing is I use the internet like
you want to [__] with my head well I'm
gonna use you and get everything I can
get out of you it's meaning like post
Clips do podcasts share everything reach
a bigger audience so there are perks
it's like fire it can burn your house
down but it can cook your food yeah yeah
that's interesting I think um
looking at how to use the internet more
healthily is a challenge for everybody
that's trying to make anything right
yeah because as soon as you post
something there's inevitable criticism I
know and posting ghosts not a bad
solution for that or just do a salmon
completely torpedo your entire account
and just exit exit the internet at large
that's another solution I guess my
friend did that and he lost 30 pounds
he's like happier he sees his kids more
because when you really look at your
phone and think about it like you get
that screen time thing oh what a kick in
the balls that is that hurts my wife's
always like I have no time and I'm like
I watched you look at Tick Tock for two
hours two out you could have watched a
movie you could have read a book you
could have flown to to Florida
well or not uh AI companions are being
created to fill the role of sexy and
playful girlfriend uh-oh amaranth is an
only fans content creator who is one of
the most followed women on Twitch and
now she's releasing an AI companion of
herself called AI amaranth so her fans
can interact with the version of her
they can chat with her ask questions and
even receive voice voice responses oh no
I mean guys are [__] the Young Dudes
are [__] it's not good because you
used to a young uglier you know what if
there's a top percent of 10 of guys who
all get laid and then the rest are just
in cells School shooters and uh you know
basements yeah yeah exactly so those
guys are all gonna turn to this the the
path of least resistance always wins so
one of the pushbacks that I spoke to one
of my friends William Costello about
this evolutionary psychology guy the
problem you have with AI girlfriends is
that there is no Prestige associated in
having one because there's no process of
selection it's the same way as saying um
I subscribe to amaranth's only fans
account on ISO special and you go well
anybody who has the price of a spare
cheeseburger per month can subscribe to
the only fans so it doesn't make you
special yeah that's good his his thought
like a slight white pill that's in there
is it should be able to Salve people
that are very lonely but it's not going
to take the place of genuine females
because it's not sufficiently satisfying
there's no Prestige because you're not
being selected and the selection thing's
very important I completely agree and
that's good that we if we start praising
these guys like my AI girlfriend's
hotter than your AI girlfriend then
we're [__] but the fact that it's not
impressive is a good sign because that
means it won't be it won't be uh praised
with AI amaranth fans will receive
instant voice responses to any burning
question they may have whether it's a
fleeting curiosity or a profound desire
amaranth's AI counterpart will be there
to provide assistance I got a Chris spot
made not that people can access but that
I can use for asking it questions on Q a
days and uh I used it and the ease that
these guys can do so they could just
take every podcast episode that you've
ever been on yeah run that through a
language learning model and there you go
there's a moderately accurate Mark Digi
Digi Mark oh my God markbuck that's a
bummer yeah sorry folks yes you don't
want two of this that's not good could
you imagine how ridiculous a AI version
of you would be oh God I know I'd be
late first of all but uh even the AI one
but I heard a comment Go on stage
because all these Comics are worried
about Ai and he did I'm gonna read a a
joke I wrote and a joke that AI wrote in
my voice and you see if you can tell and
he did both and his joke was so much
better and it made me feel a lot of
relief uh you're still light years ahead
of what the AI bot can write yeah
because comedy's all context you know
and computers can't feel context and I
think that's that's a big part of it a
computer can have a twist and a setup
and a punch but it doesn't doesn't have
that little you know when a joke bombs
as a comedian go well that bombed and
that gets a laugh but I I don't think AI
could do that someone said on a podcast
I was listening to will know that AI is
a fully conscious when it exits the
interaction and regrets not saying the
funny thing that it should have done is
it's on its way down there
wow that's brilliant yeah that's killer
but like here's a great here's a great
old joke uh you know the this is Junior
stop because joke brilliant comedian he
goes uh the Holocaust actually had a lot
of mentally challenged people in it but
you never see pictures of them because
they're all smiling
and it's a great joke but AI could never
be that Twisted to think of that and
that's why I love comedy there was a uh
it's called Doc is it called docbot
which they tried to do a version of chat
GPT but the whole thing was trained on
the dark net as opposed to on the
surface web yeah so this is all of the
[__] up
only access custom access forums and
like dark versions of 4chan and [__]
like that and they trained this thing on
that and I don't know maybe that'll be
able to do the the [__] up jokes I'm
not sure but maybe I think
I would be worried if I was a
YouTube thumbnail Creator if I was a
middling uh legal sort of litigation
person yes that's the worry yeah or if I
was like maybe a a
radiologist that's looking at scans that
are kind of relatively easy to break
down so those kind of you know they're
still quite complex jobs but those jobs
that are a little bit more automated
yeah I think comedy is probably going to
be one of the ones it's safe for a
little bit longer at least totally and
you like a guy or a gal you know you go
I like Ellie Wong you know even if I
don't love that last joke she said or
whatever you just like her or you relate
to her or you connect with her and I
think with a radiologist there's no none
of that yes so it's not just the context
of the joke it's the context of the
person that tells the joke completely
you know people go Joe Rogan that's my
guy that's my guy he's he's he fits for
me he can happily laugh at something
even if it was totally [__] exactly
they've got this warm feeling yeah I
mean I I saw Joe do a set it was maybe
the first one that I saw of him and uh
at least I would say 20 of it was
storytelling hmm you know there was it
was humorous or whatever but it was like
he did this bit about is it what's the
animal that's got the females have got
like a [__] deck is that a coyote oh is
that um uh left hyena hyena maybe yeah
and you like you're hearing him talk and
it's kind of entertaining but we're like
90 minutes into learning about the you
know like the unique physiology of
female hyenas or something I'm like this
is just a a miniature version of of the
podcast right necessarily even to do
with the joke right so a lot of the time
people go because they just feel
comfortable listening to this person
Speak oh this is familiar also you know
Joe actually gives a [__] about that yes
and that makes you give a [__] a little
more like he's not this this is kind of
funny like he's actually interested in
that hyena [__] yes so that helps
um but like Tom Hanks Tom Hanks I don't
know anything about Tom Hanks but we
love him we love Tommy if he's in a
movie you just it bumps up the box
office tenfold because we all love Tom
Hanks we know zero about him except that
he's been a [__] of a military guy a
baseball player you know an astronaut
but well I don't know anything about it
does he like chocolate is he a pedophile
or whatever you know but you like him
have you ever been down the Tom Hanks is
part of the Illuminati Rabbit Hole I
don't want to go that's terrifying we're
going so I don't even know what the
Illuminati is it's guys in a room with
masks on this one if anybody wants to
look at it Google uh Tom Hanks glove
Instagram photo so there's a sequence of
people that take photos famous people
that take photos and I think Tom was
taking photos of lost gloves that was
his thing so you'd see one on the street
and you take a photo and you put it on
his Instagram and in a bunch of the
different photos people had found a
chalk text that had been written on the
floor below it and it's downtown [__]
Denver or some [__] so you know it could
just be anything but people then started
putting these codes in on the internet
and bro it's such a rabbit hole oh yeah
it's terrifying that's so interesting
terrifying yeah I wouldn't I don't want
to go you've seen Tom hanks's son chat I
love that guy why absolutely wild dude I
love that guy good for him he when he
when he stopped that lady he's like yeah
yeah I don't give a [__] and she's like
you just think it's this this he's like
yeah that's what I think it is and I was
like yeah [__] this lady have you uh
have you ever had people kind of trying
no um flemics you and I don't know how
much news he interviewee real press [__]
you do not a ton but I've definitely had
people like so you think that and they
keep trying to gotcha you and you're
like what are we doing here I thought we
were just gonna hang out and talk or be
funny and they're like but you you so
you're saying a lot of so you're saying
I'm like no I'm not saying that at all
stop telling me what I'm thinking you
know but that's what we do because they
want that clip or they want that that
win and it's a real bummer you know so
you uh do you think Ivermectin is
whatever and I'm like I have to say it's
a Pulitzer prize-winning drug it's taken
by millions oh so you don't think it's
horsepower I'm like
you haven't heard of ivermect until two
days ago and now you're like wildly
angry about it you know like I'm not the
weirdo here you're the weirdo I I'm I'm
agnostic I don't give a [__] I'm neutral
speaking of uh try to stay neutral as
far as Gump and Tom Hanks one of my
friends is running across America at the
moment so he's doing uh 64 65 days 50
miles a day so I think a few thousand
people have been to the top of Everest
300 people have run across America wow
yeah so he's gonna be the fastest break
like a will gooj um a gooch hey uh if
people want to go and check him out they
can Google will gujan support the run
and [__] like that but he's in where is
he now he's in the Appalachian Mountains
Pennsylvania he's going from LA to New
York good for him have you heard this
new thing taken over where people do a
12-hour walk yes one of my friends did
this on Sunday really and they say after
about six seven hours first of all your
feet are bleeding you know but your
brain goes to these places because we're
so used to just being constantly under
retain phone screen computer TV Netflix
but it just go uh third grade teacher oh
summer camp and you just go to these
crazy memory banks and it's pretty wild
all of the times that you have molested
is gonna go back yeah yeah I don't need
to walk for that
um but
I think uh this is the new craze is this
like shutting down Amish uh full-on
disconnect well what's that what's that
Jewish thing that people's Shabbat is it
what's the thing where that is something
shabbat shalom why they do uh they don't
use the Sabbath kind of I think I'm
pretty sure it's called Shabbat anyway
it's from Friday evening until I think
Saturday and they don't turn on any
lights they don't do any work they don't
blah blah blah but I'm pretty sure that
in really really hardcore uh Jewish
households for some of the things that
they need to do they have it's almost
like a Shabbat servant to do things like
turning yeah
right no no people in Brooklyn these
Orthodox guys like can you come in here
and turn the light on you're kidding I
swear to God because they can't do it so
some some kid in the neighborhood's like
all right just flips it on
that's so funny it's so silly religion
is so many dumb loopholes and stuff like
that where are you living now in New
York I'm in the West Village
Um Manhattan okay so is that on the
island on the island baby you know
Greenwich Village that's Bob Dylan
Bleecker Street Washington Square Park
uh the comedy seller the whole thing NYU
did you purposefully pick the distance
from that to The Cellar too far to work
well I've always wanted to live in the
village just being a kid growing up in
the South just think about a Greenwich
Village wow you know Bill Cosby Woody
Allen all the other uh rapists but uh
you know they would all play these
coffee houses and and all that stuff so
beat Nick and folk music and all that so
I always loved it so I moved to New York
lived in Brooklyn way out got mugged got
beat up all that [__] bed bugs and then
slowly moved my way to Greenwich Village
I saw this story from some girl in New
York women are wearing a safety layer
over their outfits in public to deter
creepy men with many any labeling it's
sad but necessary this girl captioned a
clip uh the real fit is underneath
apparently it's because of weird men on
the Underground others who hadn't heard
of this Trends expressed how sad but
necessary it is this is sad someone else
called it uh what's it called a fashion
safety layer or the men blocker whoa but
there's all of these stories about just
how bad New York Subway is at the moment
totally yeah have you been on it
recently yeah I go every day it's pretty
dicey what's it like people that live in
I don't know London where the
underground is absolutely fine on Tokyo
where it's also absolutely fine what
what's the experience of getting on the
subway like at the moment well the thing
with the subway is there's a there's a
hobo count went up way way high after
the pandemic and so the subway is a
place where you have a trapped person
like you know you bump into a guy on the
sidewalk on Broadway and he's like give
me your money or I'll kill you whatever
you're like all right just keep walking
but the subway you're waiting for the
train or you're on the train so I think
hobos have been like I can get people
there the doors are closed you know
you'd have to run up the stairs or wait
for the subway to stop so I think it
started out as like now they're on the
subway I can get money out of them but
now it's kind of like I'll also fight
you why did the population increase I
think all the people moved out or stayed
indoors during the pandemic so the
homeless kind of got a little more
Brazen and like we have the city to
ourselves what was that awards ceremony
where there was tons of homeless people
was it the Golden Globes or the Oscars
or something probably they had to shift
a ton of yeah yeah yeah out that were
living in there there was like a bunch
of homeless people a lot of tent tent
homes and stuff and they had to they had
to shove them
yeah exactly four-year-old girlfriend
and then once he's gone through they're
fine exactly yeah well there was that
story about that guy who restrained a a
dude that was under warrant and arrest
and all this stuff and now he's it's not
looking too good for him okay I went
from hero to to murderer and like one
second yeah [__] brutal that's not
uncommon to see well I mean I'm sure
that someone killing somebody on the or
restraining somebody to death uh is
uncommon but like aggression and no not
uncommon at all people getting pushed on
the tracks uh just getting I have
friends who just got randomly punched in
the head you know it's just it's just
crazy people out and about
mingling with millions of New Yorkers so
it's there's gonna be some tension it's
right especially if you think coming
from the UK where we have the
underground tons you know it's not as
big as New York but it's not far off
loads of tracks everything's complex
differently it's the same it's the same
system yeah the tube and it's lovely
yeah it's great the most pleasant
experience yeah yeah borderline Pleasant
now this is uh this is like head on a
swivel all the time I did conversation
with a friend a couple of nights ago and
he was in he lives in Tokyo and as he
gets on a train he was having to text me
on Whatsapp in response to my
conversation through his airpods because
nobody speaks you're not you don't know
right no one speaks wow and he was so
concerned like there was some things
where he was finding it we were talking
he was laughing so I could hear him
stifling a laugh doing like a whisper
laugh whoa the Subway because he didn't
want to make any noise that that's a
little much yes you know I'd rather
somewhere in the middle of the choking
out and the texting but I that leads to
a lot of repression too like my point
being that you can be very civilized I
guess with the right culture you're able
to control Behavior pretty well so for
people to say
it's inevitable if you've got a ton of
people living in a city and they're all
going to be underground you know like
it's just it's part for the course what
do you expect them to do you go well
like
behave in any way that the rest of the
world does yeah maybe I know it'd be
nice but that's just not part of the
culture and as much as we [__] on
America and America's racist and full of
hate and bigoted and gun toting fat
people which there are we're pretty
considerate and pretty uh lenient with
uh nut jobs where in China Japan I feel
like if some guys were in tattered
clothes and smells like [__] and going
ah I'm gonna kill all of you they'll
just [__] knock that guy out put him
in a sack tase them and throw them over
the bridge no he's gonna make your shoes
yeah yeah or that to a desk and make
your shoes does this uh company called
Nine line apparel and they just did the
owner just found out about they did a a
test on the fabric of a particular
um garment supplier and they were able
to trace all of the garments back to
uyghur workers whoa sustainable so it's
supposed to be sustainably sourced but
it's not uh wow yeah it's [__] crazy
did there's like millions of people
maybe strapped to literally tied to
desks just sewing cheap unreal fast
fashion stuff right now 2023 right
unreal and no one cares no one's doing a
thing about it not one tweet meanwhile
in America nobody wants to work because
they're like I need health care I need
Dental I need free coffee I need snacks
I need vacation time like my wife used
to work at LinkedIn I would go there it
was beautiful I would hang out there it
was like pillows everywhere and espresso
machines and candy and a and like a uh
what do you call ice cream
booth you know and you could just go I'm
like this is the the chefs were making
lunch every day it was incredible
yeah they got the [__] suicide net
outside the Apple company Serena the
South Park episodes where Carmen gets a
job no oh it's phenomenal it's from this
newest season so uh but this gets a job
at an ice cream parlor and Carmen's
jealous because he wants a job as well
but is is his referral and says that's
okay like you can come and work but
everyone's like dude this is not gonna
last yeah someone makes a bet that you
won't last for two hours and five
minutes into the shift the boss comes
over and Carmen sat on his phone he says
what are you doing he says I'm taking a
mental health break and another five
minutes later he says oh it's um it's
like take it easy Tuesday and then I'm
looking forward to walk out early
Wednesday like you just by by the end of
it he's ringing Butters from home whilst
he's taking a mental health leave Day
saying you do know that we're earning
all of this money for the ruthless guy
that owns it and we're the ones that are
doing the work we really should own that
place yeah and uh they're on the money
man like it's those those guys they're
they're such Geniuses because they nail
everything and are funny and they never
do interviews or anything so you don't
really know how they think but they just
they gotta they get it right every time
[__] on everybody yeah it's beautiful
and no one [__] with them because
they're a cartoon yeah yeah well unless
they put a image of Muhammad up which
then that's true with that yeah that got
ugly eight years ago or something yeah
yeah well that's a whole another he's
like the ultimate Karen Muhammad you
know he's like hey how dare you we're
gonna shut this thing down it's not him
oh yeah it's true but his his you know
lackeys yeah yeah
it was they did Andrew Tate as well in
the last episode of South Park this
season so they started with uh Prince
Harry
beautiful I mean there's a wealth of
Comedy out there now it's so good Meghan
Markle and you know Dole is all as I
mentioned Trump it's just what's
happening with dollars on she's on only
fans
you're kidding me oh I'm a subscriber
yeah what do you know what she's doing
uh you know fingering tits the whole
thing fingering tits yeah well she's
she's going all in she's you know it's a
fetish and and I use her as gifts
because it's not black but it counts you
know it's it's close enough so I saw
this story about uh Prince Harry has
lost a legal challenge over his bid to
be allowed to make private payments for
the police his lawyers want a
jurisdictional review of the rejection
of his offer to pay for protection in
the UK uh a judge ruled not to give the
go-ahead home office allows have opposed
the idea of allowing wealthy people to
buy security from the police so I wasn't
really too sure about how I felt about
this I don't know what is it can you uh
translate that so
Prince Harry no longer has his normal
protection from being a royal because he
lost his Royal status he it seems has
security concerns when he travels to the
UK so his plan was to just pay for
police to come with him so that there
would be a degree of protection but also
so that it didn't chew into the police's
budget for whichever area of the country
is got it so you'll have seen it um the
mothership there is a like a low-key
couple of cops that are on site sure and
they're paid for privately but they're
you know official I'm going to presume
that they're not they're probably off
duty still sanctioned yeah I think I
don't really know how it works
up until I'd seen that I'd never really
heard about anybody being able to pay
for
private police protection but it
actually makes a good bit of sense
because if you don't
if you don't allow somebody that's going
to be heavily scrutinized and caused
loads of you know before amongst the
public to actually have some protection
they're gonna have to go in any case
yeah crowd control so just let them pay
I guess yeah but they said no no they
said no I think there's a big a big
problem especially in the UK of allowing
like wealth in the UK has really really
looked down on especially ostentatives
yeah so if you were to say I'm going to
use the money that I've accrued to buy
the usage of what is typically seen as a
a public service it's one of the reasons
why
people in the UK forget that you can get
private healthcare because the NHS is
there so they would happily wait six
months for their cancer to metastasize
so they can get their scan for free
right then think about paying for
insurance they'll pay for their dogs
Insurance English Bulldog they'll be a
hundred bucks a month or a couple
hundred bucks a month yeah but they
won't think about doing it for
themselves interesting and I think that
the UK has a bit of a problem with
people using wealth especially to sort
of chew up services wow well hey I mean
you know this kind of feels like the the
defund the police people who immediately
call the police right when Anything Goes
Down
yeah I like that guy yeah he's great he
was on CNN a couple of nights ago and
they were talking about why have we got
these increases in crime and homicides
and it got toward the end of the segment
and Coleman was like I have an idea yeah
what is it he said refund the police and
they cut the segment
shortly after that uh we're gonna have
to we're gonna we'll leave it there
Coleman thank you see that's what bugs
me not to spin off into another thing
but that's what bugs me about the times
we're living in is
yeah I don't you know I get there we
can't have certain opinions but we
should at least be able to discuss
everything like I know that's a
different differentiating opinion than
CNN you know they have to go with the
narrative they have to go with the check
boxes but
let's hear him out you know like like
you bring up drag queens and I don't
give a [__] about drag queens I don't
have kids it doesn't affect me but just
bring it up my friend was like oh dude
dude let's not even go there and I'm
like why not that's the world no on a
podcast but that's why it weirds me out
I'm like so we can't talk about it to
not be able to talk about it to me is
weirder than the actual activity and
that's what no one is understanding you
know they're like oh you got a problem
with drag queens or you like drag queens
I'm like no no I'm neutral but I'd like
to discuss it and see if we can get some
situation it's an interesting situation
but then they're like shut it down shut
it down or cut that out I'm like now
that's the scary part to cut that out
what are you so scared of what is that
feeling like oh this is this is bad
we're in the red shut it down abort and
I'm like that's what worries me it's
because nobody is not allowed to have an
opinion on everything anymore like
everybody has to have an opinion right
on absolutely everything and uh
and I just want to learn I'm an idiot so
I want to learn more but they just say
uh like trans is a big one so what's up
with Tran if this is that then what's up
with that and you go and you're like
well now now I'm really interested it's
kind of when I was a kid I was I was an
atheist and you know you go so wait If
Heaven is real and Heaven is
uh Blissful eternity then are you old in
heaven because that wouldn't be Blissful
I'd rather be young also is my grandma
in there and is she old or is she uh and
you start asking and they go ah shut the
[__] up yeah how dare you uh you know
you're talking the the name of God and
all this [__] you know the lord's name
in vain and you're like oh you have no
answer and I feel like that's the same
with all this stuff and I just want to
learn I'm not trashing Heaven I'd love
to go to heaven but I want to get to the
bottom of it and they get they start
getting angry and that's what worries me
my friend's got this uh theory of
bespoke [__] many people don't have
an opinion until they're asked for it at
which point they Cobble together a
Viewpoint from women half remembered
hearsay before deciding that this two
minute old makeshift opinion will be
their new Hill to die
[__] bird who is this guy yeah it's
the same dude is on fire gwynda bogalier
wrote this phenomenal article he's like
I forced this guy onto the show probably
every three or four months or so and
he's basically a digital ghost apart
from tweeting aphorisms like that and
writing awesome sub stacks and uh I just
like drag him Kicking and Screaming yeah
Place him on a podcast and then he
scores away and learn some more good
[__] and then I drag him back and bring
him back on again here's the question
why does he have to be a digital ghost
because he doesn't want all the backlash
and the [__] yeah but like we're
just trying to learn it does seem that
way the um
the the fact that everybody feels like
they need to have an opinion on
everything means that you remember the
uh silence is violence oh that was a
good one silence is compliance yeah
thing it's like well
if you're if you're pushing people to
take a particular position and you can
only allow them to either be for or
against a thing you're going to lose all
of the interesting stuff out of having
conversation completely they're not
going to bother and it's only science is
violence if you don't if you're not
saying my thing you know like it's like
when people go we need more diversity
and you're like what do you mean like
you need more people look like me like
oh you want you want to be on the show
you know you're not thinking about the
uh Pacific Islander you know or the
wheelchair guy you're thinking about you
so I get there we're all selfish at the
end of the day but you get to be selfish
and mask it with this guys of of uh
moral superiority yeah the performative
empathy thing is
one of the reasons why I think everyone
I I do think it contributes to the
cynicism because it's so hard to work
out whether someone's being genuine or
not yes yes is this person actually
doing the thing that they say that they
do
cause they care yes or are they doing it
because they know that it's an effective
current social Trend to ride off the
back of exactly exactly and you can see
which way the wind's blowing and most
people I think just go I'll go that way
because I don't want to deal with
getting yelled at and backlash and
remember what is it
um only 10 of Americans have a Twitter
account
so 90 of Americans don't have a Twitter
account wow which means that you know
and I think on Twitter it's around about
95 of tweets are created by less than 20
or 10 of the users so even there is a
small cohort of people from the world
who are on Twitter and within the people
that are on Twitter there is a small
cohort of them yeah produce almost all
of the content right so the overwhelming
majority opinion that you see is
actually unbelievably unrepresentative
they incredibly small and biased yeah
because all of the people that tweet a
lot you know there will be something in
common that everybody has it's like you
see someone post a something negative or
there's a flood of negative comments and
you go I wonder what all of those people
have gone in common because they will
there will be some things some elements
of Personality that will contribute to
have that be there totally it's not a
representative sample no no but they
they swarm they'll swarm on you and it
feels like a million people yeah
Jonathan height called it death by
little needles you know just like you
know one one needle prick you're like oh
that was weird but a million of them
coming at you that hurts John Heights
doing some interesting stuff you've seen
that he's writing his entire book
publicly at the moment what does that
mean so he he's got I think it's maybe a
sub stack of some other sort of mailing
list and he's got this book that's going
to be out at some point in the future
and each maybe a few pages or each
chapter as he writes them he's just
publishing ah as he goes that's pretty
good and then he's getting feedback in
the comments and then presumably we'll
be making adjustments before the final
comedy it's like stand up yes wow he's
doing a live act and then editing yes
based on the reaction you did a special
I did one yeah it comes out July 25th on
Netflix and they let me say everything
they I mean I really go hard I was
shocked at no notes
so I think maybe things are changing or
maybe Netflix once because any press is
good press so when you mean notes it was
you were able to submit it and they
didn't say
we can't have that joke VR word out all
that nah Holocaust trans it's all in
there and uh everything's a joke
everything gets a laugh but it's uh it's
all the all the hot button topics uh I
asked Schultz this question do you think
that there's any joke that is so
extreme that it shouldn't be told
I don't but
I'm a comedian who likes [__] up jokes
he said uh is it funny that's I
completely agree and I was like uh yeah
yeah and I oh sorry I would apparently
it matters funny as if it's funny it's a
stand-up comedy show at the end of the
day even if someone has a non-offensive
joke that isn't funny I say get rid of
it it doesn't matter if it's offensive
or edgy or whatever or or not edgy get
rid of it either way if it's not getting
a laugh
um funny is a is a you know what's that
Oscar Wilde if you're going to tell the
truth you better be funny or they'll
kill you and I think that's so true and
I would say the same for these people
who their whole Act is like I was
molested I was the victim of racism and
you're like
that's easy anybody get molested or be a
victim of racism that's easy what the
hard part is to get in the laugh anybody
get molested that's not an
accomplishment you know it's it sucks
but we gotta get the the hahas in there
that's what Sam comedy that's why it's
an art form and that's why it's fun it's
the whole point yeah I uh I was using
this example did you see true Geordie do
you know who that is I I've heard of
them but I don't know YouTube guy from
the UK and he does podcasts big guy yeah
yeah and um he's from the city where I
used to live and um Jake Paul hates Jake
Paul yes I think not a massive fan of
Jake Paul
um he told a joke him and Andrew Tate
had a run-in for quite a long time
and someone asked on a live stream
forever ago uh what do you think about
Andrew Tate's recent conversion to Islam
and Brian trajodi said uh
he should prove it to us all by blowing
himself up
that's a good line that's a good joke
yeah it's a legitimate joke and Andrew
said the same he was like it was obvious
misdirect he was playing off tropes like
it's just it's classic classic yeah I
love it and he got within 24 hours uh my
protein dropped him Jim shark dropped
him PokerStars dropped him and he was
banned on Twitch wow
24 hours see that's that's horrible and
what annoys me about when people are
like he's got money he'll be fine shut
up he's fine you're like he lost all
that that sucks that's over a joke so
when they say like oh shut up when
you're complaining you can't oh comics
can't say anything look I still say
everything I want but this guy said one
quick thing about a guy who's pretty
well hated and he's still got in trouble
yeah
that sucks I hate the whole he'll be
fine because you're like Okay so let's
say
you call Michael Jordan the n-word at a
game he's a millionaire Bubba he went to
work the next day he's fine so that that
doesn't matter
it still should matter I don't get why
uh calling someone a bigot and then
calling someone the n-word is is uh not
the same well the the problem that you
have especially if you look at I don't
know
someone's quality of life based on how
much money they're able to earn or how
much money they've got in the bank
account completely disregards the fact
that status is so important to the way
that we feel about ourselves yes yes
right if you have this massive downfall
yes everybody hates you and there's all
of this bad stuff and you know if
someone's righteously indignant about
the joke that you made against their
religion or their race or their
disability or their advertising campaign
or whatever they're going to be unhappy
but like that person is going to suffer
a lot you have to be really really
[__] hard-nosed to go through a
massive downfall totally what was it
that Rogan said like the way that he
dealt with his little uh his thing a
couple of years ago was like a moderate
dose of mushrooms pretty much every
single day yeah that was one of the
framework like training a lot and I did
an ice bath and my diet was clean and I
took a lot of mushrooms yeah and you
think well I don't know man like
that's a lot of stuff just get through
the day precisely from somebody that's
got an awfully long way to fall yeah
like accrued a good bit of status and
and Goodwill below them and still
there's all of these things that you
need to do oh he'll be fine well
yeah like the daily psychedelics and
exactly training suggests that it's not
just the sort of thing that you can
easily get through I I think it's
horrible I think calling someone a
[__] is mean that hurts their feelings
I get it it's funny but I get it when
they're like hey we got to stop saying
that word and I think the same goes for
people who just call everybody racist or
a bigot or a transpho or whatever when
they're not you know like if I if I kiss
you that doesn't make me gay I just did
a gay thing for a second and if I make a
racist joke or say a a bad word I don't
mean that thing I just did it for a
second
you see what I'm saying and that's what
bugs me at what point do you become gay
I think when you're attracted to men but
how many gay things do you have to do
before you become gay I think it's all
up here it's like being a woman I
identity you identify suck your dick and
be straight yeah yeah because it's
sucking a dick is a it's just a physical
act act right actually wanting to suck a
dick that's when you're gay interesting
yeah so
blow it you could blow me right now and
I won't call you gay I promise
that mustache I want to jizz all over it
yeah I've been trying to sort of really
uh
Channel my 1970s Miami cup it looks good
I'm good yeah [__] yeah I'd sit on that
I'm uh I'm a Rangers Fan I'm a Texas
Rangers Fan now oh nice baseball what do
I need to know everyone like about
American sport what are the the skills
that I need to be able to watch American
sport well what do you mean the skills
well you gotta be fair you gotta be
drunk yep these things yeah yeah what is
that what you like because I haven't
been to a baseball game since I've moved
here what should I expect get a cold
beer uh you gotta learn the hey and then
there's also the whole culture of like
trashing the guy from the stands like
you call that a throw I've seen better
throws on a pillow or whatever on a rug
you know and that's all fun and games
and then maybe you can catch a fly ball
that's big then you got to give it to
the [__] cancer kid with the bald
head so there's all kinds of tropes um
it's fun it's fun you go out in the sun
take your shirt off live it up man it's
the American Pastime [__] yeah bring
sunflower seeds I needed I decided that
I needed a uh I needed something I
needed a sport and team that I could
follow in Texas Ranges owned by what
were the reasons we wanted a place that
had a nice Stadium Place that wasn't
more than three hours away place that
was owned by racists and it turns out
that George George Bush the Bush family
is just heavily invested in the brand
new stadium for the Rangers I love it so
we got all three oh you're gonna have a
blast uh I went to when I went to
Australia one time I went to I don't
even know the name of the sport cricket
that was the thing was it Cricket go
careful here this is the spot of my
childhood no no that wasn't correct
because I know Cricket that's got the
paddle yeah this was more of a soccer
rugby kind of thing oh Aussie Rules
Football maybe that was it and it was
amazing went to the big Stadium the
whole place
have you seen uh hurling have you seen
that the Irish sport no so you've seen
lacrosse
yes with the Nets the Nets and the thing
and they like run like that yeah so
imagine that but instead of it being a
net and a little ball it's a wooden like
a big hockey stick and they run sort of
balancing the ball on the hockey stick
what but it means that they can swing
this thing unbelievably none of the
players have got any teeth it's like
whoa It's kind of the same as ice hockey
without the ice or the skating wow it's
absolutely you have to balance it while
running running yeah so they do this
it's [__] crazy man hurling look at
it and they could hit you with the stick
they swing through a lot of the time oh
my Lord no helmet uh I can't remember I
feel like the goalies got a helmet but
not them wow and then there's Gaelic
football if you've seen that which is
literally like halfway between rugby and
football so they have the rugby stands
with the the thing yeah and the bottom
bit has got a net and got a goalie in it
whoa so you got to try and score in that
you can get it over the top and there's
other bits and pieces
I love it well what about you FC that's
to me that's my favorite is that what
you're spending a lot of time watching
at the moment that's my number one I
like a one-on-one like I like tennis too
I like one-on-one I like the mental part
of it I like the different like this
fighter is better than this fighter but
he can still beat him because of the
style differences you know I love that
kind of stuff and I loved learning you
know Nate Diaz as a character Conor
McGregor is a character uh style Bender
you get to know them whereas football is
just a bunch of nameless faceless
helmets and I like that where you can
kind of get them if it's more like stand
up I went to Columbia at the start of
the year to get stem cells so I spent a
full week in Medellin and my wow in
clinic like patient partner was Al
Jermaine Sterling whoa so I could spend
a full week with him what's he like
[__] cool dude yeah very just like a
chill not like
them it's a compliment but unbelievably
normal yeah like incredibly normal and I
get the sense that if I'd spent the week
with sugar Shawn it would have been less
normal with Conor McGregor would have
been less normal but there are you know
this is you know getting towards being
super super dominant within what's the
three-time defending champ now yeah
something like that that's a 135 belt
yeah and uh next fight's gonna be
against sugar Shawn so yeah he was
really really normal super nice guy
texted his team on the night that he had
the fight and wishing him good luck and
stuff and that's [__] cool man what
they're doing I haven't hasn't the UFC
partnered with WWE oh is that right I
hope I'm not pretty I'm absolutely
certain WWE UFC I promise you that I'm
gonna bring this up I hope it doesn't
get too wrestling yeah where are we uh
the yeah the WWE UFC merger whoa yeah
this is a month old now World Wrestling
Entertainment WrestleMania is the
biggest event uh
on April 2nd the second day of
WrestleMania CNBC broke the news that
the WWE's to be sold to Hollywood talent
agency Endeavor group Holdings Endeavor
which also owns the UFC is to merge the
two iconic complementary Global sports
and entertainment Brands to form a new
21 Billion Dollar Plus live sports and
entertainment no they took the money
Dana White you [__] God damn it I hope
there's not I don't want to see just
engage you get hit with a folding chair
how far are we gonna take this I hope
they don't mesh too much bring the
Dudley boys back yeah yeah what is it a
Royal Rumble but in the Octagon right
now Rogan's gonna have to be us the new
slim jim guy oh yeah oh boy yeah funny
man I don't know I feel like everything
kind of descends towards WWE well it's
interesting because WWE basically what
they did was
they realized if we got rid of the sport
element of the sport and we tried to
create all of the drama as effectively
as possible what would we end up zeroing
in on so they've split tested the same
way that you have with jokes for forever
yeah they've split tested
what makes a compelling character and a
narrative and rivalry yes story yes so
when people say uh this is becoming like
WWE what they mean is this is descending
more into Showmanship it what's happened
is WWE has captured the most effective
way to create rivalry and Intrigue and
storyline in sport yeah you know what I
mean completely 100 I mean it's as old
as time good guy bad guy the fitive
battle of the strongest wins and then
you get the we hate you more you're the
heel yeah and you play it up it's it's
it's it's nothing new but it works well
that's Jake Paul right Jake Paul's you
know professionalized the heel yeah
someone [__] said about that when
there was talk about before Andrew Tate
was under house arrest uh there was talk
about Jake Paul versus an Andrew Tate
fight and you think who's the bad guy
right who's supposed to be the bad guy
in this fight well I will take it one
step further this Jake Paul date but
there's also AOC and Marjorie Taylor
green that's also WWE did you see the
image the AI only funds in enhanced
image of AOC no please lay it on me I'm
gonna get hard I'm wearing a bathing
suit here dude it's so [__] good
attack she's very attractive I texted
this to Rogan a couple of weeks ago
oh come on yeah that's that's nothing to
sneeze at and it says uh the caption
above it says will you give me your guns
now and the Tweet is you give me your
guns I'll give you these cannons
the top the top rated comment was uh
what was it
uh this is an attack quick objectifying
the people who are helping to make our
country and the place it needs to be the
right and right the wrongs of the past
and give way for the future I was like
he nearly killed my erection there good
try
oh man but that's the other thing is uh
I I talked to Schultz about this I think
when the Miller Lite ad came out he's
like look I get it women started Brewing
first but can't we just have fun can we
just enjoy beer that's the real problem
with the ads it's not like I don't think
a lot of people like [__] women put them
in bikinis ah it's just like I I'm just
getting lectured here about a [__]
poison that I want to drink to forget
about my job you know well it's I think
one of the main problems people have is
they just seem like such humorless
Pricks yes yes exactly not Charming no
Charming for the people that haven't
seen especially the British people
haven't seen this Miller Light ad it was
basically snuck in under the radar at
the same time as the Dylan Mulvaney
thing and I think it the lady that's
presenting it is maybe a LGBT person too
yeah and she's walking through a museum
and saying women brood beer and how did
we reward them we rewarded them by
putting them in bikinis and it cuts to a
1990s ad of two girls mud wrestling in
the middle of the street and it's like
eBay Miller Lite and you're into girls
mud wrestling or whatever which is true
people that drink Miller like probably
are yeah into that sort of stuff and
then the lady's castigating anybody that
thinks that's cool and is like we're
committed to changing the and you just
think I think a lot of things first off
I think
how [__] tone deaf do you need to be
about your own audience yeah how [__]
confident do you need to be in your
share price and your sales figures oh
yeah and how little fun are you exactly
so humorless I know like why can't uh
progressiveness and inclusiveness be fun
too like what also
not to be this guy but what's so bad
about bikinis like aren't all these
women and only fans very empowering you
know I thought that was empowering like
hey we're taking our sexuality back we
make money on it we do what we want
that's empowering I'm allowed to
objectify myself but you're not allowed
to objectify me I guess but it's not
like we we tased a woman and knocked her
out and put her in a burlap sack and
then said you're in this bikini
commercial or we'll kill you you know
she I'm sure thousands of women
auditioned and we're like I got it I got
the Miller Light ad with the twins well
do you remember
Diet Coke that yes all of the women
looking out over that no God not one guy
complained about that I'm looking
forward to becoming skinny fat in middle
age and being able to point at that and
say that was what caused me to lose my
gains I was objectified I didn't want to
be seen as a sex object yeah not just a
piece of meat it's so funny how bad I
want to be objectified I would love a
woman to objectify me but I guess it's a
supply and demand they get it so much
that they're like I'm annoyed I've got
no objectification left to give Mark I'm
afraid there's no more yeah it's uh it's
so [__] weird man I just
I really hope that we're around the
corner from something that's going to be
different in terms of like cultural
memes because I'm kind of exhausted of
it as well I think what I think a lot of
people are and I think it's almost like
a fever breaking like these Bud Light
and Miller Lite and the Starbucks and
the Starbucks thing the Starbucks is uh
it's pretty great it's a old Indian guy
and he gets a call from his son says the
sun pops up on the screen and he's like
ah damn and then in comes his new
daughter so that the sun transitioned so
the daughter comes in and he's like
[__] you know he's all angry and
the mom's like come on be nice and he's
like you know what you're right let's
get a coffee and that's the ad
so he's accepted as trans daughter they
bond over going to Starbucks yes exactly
but it's just so forced and I think it's
great that he's accepting his trans
though that's great and it's I'm all for
the love and everything I want everybody
to get along fake Indian man is
accepting his fake lady and yeah
exactly to then go and shamelessly
she'll a multi-billion dollar yes
Enterprise exactly and my my joke was
he's I think he's really mad because his
brother did the operation you know the
the Indian doctor but yeah I I just
think it just feels forced and again why
can't it be a funny ad like if it's cool
with trans person a person transitioning
but like make it fun why does it have to
be so somber and and educational dude
the Miller Lite the Bud Light thing the
releasing uh so this earlier on Bud
Light is set to launch a line of
camouflage aluminum bottles that promote
the folds of Honor program which
provides educational scholarships for
family these have fallen and disabled
the American military service members
and First Responders the New York Post
response reported so basically
there is just this permanent flip-flop
between the two now the Bud Light thing
the relatively very unpopular opinion
for me to say
I feel bad for Bud Light
because that was evidently a small
influencer campaign that some portion
that some
advertising exec somewhere that's not in
no position but isn't the [__] owner
right and isn't the shareholders and
isn't all of the people that do most of
the things some small portion that
didn't have sufficient oversight decided
that they were just going to Chuck this
set of cans to Dylan Mulvaney yeah not
realizing how badly it was going to go
down and now two huge big dick marketing
execs have been fired this has been
halted and now they're trying to do all
of this backtracking stuff so even
within that and I don't think that Dylan
Mulvaney is going to tap into the core
demographic of but like
even within that what you see is the
desire for people on both sides of the
fence to become offended like
immediately yes yes you want to have
this knee-jerk reaction to be able to go
see see this [__] woke washing these
cooked [__] leftist organizers they
took our beer exactly like they took
everything and I don't deny that it's a
[__] shitty idea a shitty advertising
campaign that doesn't Target the right
people and I don't think that Del
Mulvaney should have been used but I do
also think that going does this
represent how long has Bud Light been
around probably [__] forever right is
this really oh finally here's the mask
off that shows that they were the
America hating leftist cook CCP
sympathizing bastards that we thought of
all along well you say that if somebody
says one accidentally slightly untoward
racist thing that that doesn't color
their entire history but you're not
necessarily prepared to give the same
that's good that's good great freedom to
the other side great call Great call so
you're saying to the to the people angry
about the the new Trans guy or
translated being their sponsor you can't
just judge it all in one commercial yeah
yeah I completely agree and if you like
Bud Light just keep drinking it but
that's a good beer it's a good beer and
it's very popular what was it they had
uh the Bud Light has reportedly told
wholesalers that it will buy back unsold
cases of beer that are passed their
expiration date uh 23 down year-on-year
sales last week wow and they're doing
um camouflage print in an effort to
boost sales they're doing all sorts of
stuff so there I mean [__] dude can you
imagine being I don't know the CEO or
the chief MD or whatever of Bud Light
I'm waking up one morning and going uh
like looking at your phone and being
like so we're trending oh brilliant
What for yeah it's not brilliant sir
right right but
what about the whole any press is good
press is that just is that a myth
because this is the most press you can
get it's all we're talking about it's
all any I mean any Comedy Club if
someone's drinking a Bud Light it's boom
right to you joke joke
how can this not be good does Bud Light
know something we don't know and then
every other beer company in Starbucks
and all these other Dove are doing it so
is there something we're missing or or
is this just a huge [__] up I think it's
a [__] up okay so I have a friend who
has spent a lot of time doing e-commerce
and they've split tested bigger girls
and they've split tested girls that are
fit and he told me we have all of the
data bigger girls don't sell clothes
yeah so when you look at Victoria's
Secret someone that's trying to undo
their CIS heteronormative patriarchal
misogynistic presuppositions of what a
woman's body shape is supposed to be
like
they are paying a price with the top
line and their bottom line and
eventually some shareholders somewhere
that owns [__] 15 of the company is
going to look at a report and say
what's going on here and you go ah no
sir it's this you see it's this really
cool social movement that we're a part
of at the moment it's like it's real
it's super Progressive yeah it's very
good you know for the the Gen Zed uh 15
to 18 sort of left and he's going to say
get [__] where's put the girls that
sell clothes back yeah so there is some
criticism like get what go broke uh I
have a friend that's done a [__] ton of
analysis on this and the Gillette ad
from a few years ago didn't didn't
impact long term didn't impact their
positioning and a couple of others I'd
love him to run the stats back on these
and see what happens longer term I think
really huge Brands like a Bud Light or a
Nike Nike with uh Colin Kaepernick tons
of people took offense to that campaign
I wear them every single day yeah
first off when it's a product if the
product's good you kind of don't care I
don't care and secondly if it's a big
enough brand over a long enough period
of time people forget true you know but
like it may take them it may take them
five years probably won't but it may
take them five years to get themselves
back and we realized that we made some
mistakes with this thing and
they'll be back selling Vision soon
enough of course of course it's a it's a
fun blip in the whole thing we get to
trash it make fun of it but I do
appreciate the swing they took a swing
they seemed like they were the first one
to try it and it was a big swing and it
[__] up but sometimes you gotta try a
crazy idea and sometimes it [__] up
like like got milk got milk was huge
what's got milk got milk was this ad
milk was just going down in America
everybody hated milk it just people
turned on it got milk was this one ad
where a guy's eating a peanut butter
sandwich and it's all close up and he's
watching a movie and he's like and the
phone rings and he's like oh hello and
it's like you've won the million dollar
prize just gotta answer this one
question and then whatever the question
was was about dinosaurs and they show
his wall and it's full of dinosaur
posters he knows everything about done
he's got dioramas and all this [__] and
he's like
and they're like we can't understand you
you lost and then it goes got milk like
a milk glass of milk would have gotten
the food down right
huge ad campaign people at t-shirts got
milk just billboard said got milk milk
skyrocketed it went through the roof and
it changed everything milk stocks have
never been higher huge milk stocks so I
think Bud Light was like it's so crazy
it might just work so I think you take a
shot every now and then that's kind of
fun yeah I
I don't know man again with the delivery
let's say that they'd and this would be
an interesting question to ask you know
the most Ardent like Matt Walsh I'd love
to ask Matt Walsh hey Matt had it have
been funny
are entertaining yeah what would you
have thought like would it have been
because we said is there a joke that's
so offensive that it should never be
told if it's funny no I agree right so
if an advert is entertaining and good
should it have not been put out you go
well there's probably some limits
because it kind of creates uh role model
you know talking about kids and
positioning and [__] like that but it's
about 21 plus in this country pretty
much every state in order to be able to
drink uh so I don't know had it been had
it been entertaining but it was just
yeah I wondered I wanted to find this
out
um can you imagine how much you could
sell a Della nolvaney can of Bud Light
for because there's only six pack of
them that was ever created if she
started oh huge money yeah crazy that's
like that monkey nft you know that's
gonna be very new body yeah Dylan yeah
but I do think there is they were
tapping into something the right way I
think there's controversy can lead to
huge numbers and huge sales like trying
controversy when you're a beer brand I
guess not but like Lil Nas X you know
that guy blood yeah he's not gay I heard
so I'm not gay he's not gay it's just
all uh uh adding on to his his brand
Google this is Lil Nas X and A lot of
people hate him because he's gay he's a
devil guy he's against conservative
values Christian values Lil Nas X came
out as gay being the only artist to do
so whilst having a number one record but
you're saying I'm saying that was a
branding move very smart marketing very
smart little nazx came out this game the
last day of pride month whilst he was
number one that seems feels very
calculated Lil nazak says music industry
wants lgbtq plus artists to be gay
without being gay
this is pretty good no it's just what I
heard I'm not saying wants to be more
gay prove it yeah blow me cut yourself
in here yeah I saw him uh I saw him
perform at Austin City Limits oh wow
last year like that's one of those
things you know when you see you've been
to see a ton of bands and
the the shows are between a thousand and
two thousand and it's like about it's
like a normal band right and then you go
and see a performance like a little Nars
X thing and the guy's sprinting off
stage to do [__] costume changes and
[__] in between songs and it's all
choreographed and the dance numbers and
then he comes out and he's on a harness
and he's flying through the air and
there's a helicopter and like all sorts
of stuff you go oh okay this is
different yes yeah this is something
else this is no longer a musical exact
rendition this is a [__] like this
performance art right right and I think
I think which genes about him is Bud
Light you have to go buy Bud Light and
people see you drink it at a bar and
everybody makes fun of you this you can
put in your iPod and your your earphones
and you still sell the song but you
don't have to be seen with it no public
branding yeah did you see when Harry
Potter first came out and it was super
popular and people hadn't read it but
adults didn't want to be seen in public
reading a children's book oh they
released adult covers
of Harry Potter so that it looked less
children genius uh so I wonder whether
people are going to get Koozies
over their Bud Light yeah this is Corona
yeah yeah yeah yeah well they should do
this for Kitty porn just put a a an
adult woman on the cover and then there
you go all right that's my last Kitty
porn pedophile joke because it's getting
a little weird I asked uh an ethicist a
porn ethicist whether or not
uh Illustrated like anime or Manga child
porn is unethical
manga you know like anime okay manga an
anime like hentai right I guess it would
be called uh whether that's unethical uh
because let's say that you're able to
reduce real world harm
by having illustrations nobody's been
hurt with the illustration perhaps the
illustrator interesting uh and you're
getting it out a little bit now you have
to touch a kid because you're getting it
out at home Real Worlds uh concerns have
been a real world damage has been
reduced it's pedophile methadone
is a is a child sex robot unethical yeah
yeah that is tough well I think this you
could say this for Woody Allen like
aside from the uh touching his
daughter's accusations he married his
adopted kid
right soon Yi and obviously that's weird
but they're still married
they love each other
is it wrong
[__] crazy man so I learned about
um why we have incest aversion Ryan long
was going to try and do he texted me
about like he listened to the episodes
where I spoke about he was like I'm
gonna try and work this into a into a
set I was like dude if you manage to get
this concept into a set I'll be very
[__] impressed yeah so the reason
that you have brothers and sisters older
brother Okay cool so the reason that you
don't want to [__] your brother is
something called the Western Mark effect
so between the ages of about two and I
think it's 12. there is a window of time
and if you are around another young
child who you see interacting with your
parents in particular kinds of ways
there is a bucket in your mind that that
individual goes into that means that
you're going to be sexually repulsed by
them now the reason that this is
interesting is you can imagine a
scenario in which twins maybe or brother
and sister are separated at Birth or
separated perhaps in early childhood and
then come together later on and they can
find it they've got loads in common well
of course you do you share maybe 50 or
25 of your genetics together
um
so they go apart and then they come back
and you go you know how disgusting is it
how terrible is it for brother and
sister to have sex it's like it's pretty
bad like yeah you're gonna procreate
it's pretty bad but the reason that you
have an aversion to it has got nothing
to do with your genetics it's everything
to do with this Western Mark window the
same thing happens interesting with
fathers so if you have an absentee
father you know a lot of single mother
households and stuff where kids grow up
in Father leaves comes back into the
daughter's life perhaps at 16 for
whatever reason and maybe some daddy
issues might contribute to it but
generally you there is a lack of incest
aversion that goes on there
so you've got this father that comes
back in whoa the abandonment finally
being accepted by a man a man that I
have a lot in common with because you do
you know it's he's literally 50 of your
genes so yeah pretty [__] crazy so
this Western Mark window is is a a key
period and you can also have another way
um
adopted siblings who are not genetically
related can find massive incest aversion
to each other because even though yeah
because they just went through that
window together yeah wow how cool that's
super cool and I'm lucky because my
family is not attractive so that helps
but wow that is thank God for that that
that's a good uh advertisement for for
the nuclear family keeping a family
together to make sure that you keep your
brothers and sisters apart
yes clip it [__] yeah that's a great
commercial uh Target partners with a
Satanist brand for Pride collection uh
live laugh lesbian a new Pride
collection introduced by Target includes
clothing made by a UK based brand whose
design has expressed Satanist views a
london-based company created t-shirts
and tote bags that include messages like
live laugh lesbian cure transphobia not
trans people too queer for me and we
belong everywhere uh they made kids uh
it was up to a devil like
also sells apparel that includes satanic
imagery including pentagrams horn skulls
and references to the devil so here's
here's the thing did you see was it Sam
Smith he performed as like a a big black
blob kind of thing yeah white guy but
big black blob oh yeah he was wearing a
black yeah inflatable he came out and he
was like there was double horns and
whatever whatever and a bunch of people
especially sort of Christian
commentators were like yeah you see it's
this thing
and I get it but it does seem like the
more conspiratorial elements of of
America I don't think that it's great to
have a devil up on stage but I don't
know I
it to me there's no more existential
difference between that and it being
Mickey Mouse or it being you know like
for anything else it's just fine it's
all fake yeah yeah I don't believe in
the devil either no but like if you had
Santa Claus up on stage it's what you
represent it's like well but the
difference is the devil's equated with
evil yeah okay
yeah no like if you had Thanos if
someone went up and they would Rusty
right right or Darth Vader yeah yeah I
don't know it's just it's the
moral Panic to some regard over like
satanic imagery
I don't know my position on it yet I
might come back come around to it in a
couple of years time and say actually
yeah no [__] do you we can't have this
it's turning all of the kids into
satanists right well it's funny what
imagery you're allowed to have like uh
somebody I can't remember who some
Community had a great bit about how as a
kid you could dress up as a pirate and
Pirates are rapists and thieves and
pieces of [__] like drunkards and they
would steal your boat until like take
your money and your women pillaging yeah
but like if you dress up as a Nazi
you're a piece of [__] but like they're
both evil Pirates are one of the few
fancy dress
categories that as of yet the
cancellation hammock hasn't yeah that's
true I think because there's nothing
it'll take from them except I don't know
an eye patch or I don't know it's all
these like uh like Captain Phillips did
you ever see that movie yes yeah those
are pirate those are the modern day
Pirates yeah if you dressed your son up
as a Somali yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
but
it's just weird how like like Tony
Soprano is like this praised guy he's a
cool guy but he's a [__] sociopathic
murderer yes you know but we we pick and
choose like well he had a family and he
was funny and likable but he was a
murderer but that's the thing if you're
able to be charming and funny and
entertaining with it people will allow
so much oh yeah like Barack Obama I I
don't look I don't know anything about
politics but all I hear is he killed
millions of people and all these
innocent families and he bombed them uh
but he's cool as [__] and good looking
good speaker or fun recently narrated a
series on Netflix about nature I think
yeah nature [__] I don't give a [__]
that he uh did all those things I mean
it's horrible I guess but I you know out
of sight out of mind well wasn't that
the same Bill Clinton's widely regarded
as one of the most Charming people
that's ever totally this earth right
totally anybody that's ever met him in
person felt like they were the only one
in the room yes yes there's all of these
stories millions of stories right that
I've heard about this and you go yeah I
can see can see why he managed to get
through all of the difference guys and
all the rest of it so yeah there's um
charm I guess goes a long way it's like
uh Samuel Jackson said it's one Charming
[__] Pig uh Pulp Fiction but
yeah like he's like I don't dig on swine
because it's the same reason we don't
need dogs they're Charming but we eat
pigs because they're gross and ugly
didn't anyone say that charm is makeup
for men yes wow good memory well done
what do you mean well I mean like like
you know when you have like a one night
stand most guys typically want the lady
to get out of there because we don't
want to be Charming again it's a lot of
work being Charming is exhausting so
like you just want to be done with it
and I think women feel the same way
we're like hey you want to come over and
they're like I'm not wearing makeup but
I want to put it on and put on an outfit
I'm in my pajamas here so that's our our
makeup
Charming confidence
I'm not confident
but I gotta fake it on a date you've got
to put the effort in yeah you gotta ramp
it up beforehand exactly so when guys
are like I need this girl out of my
apartment uh uh it's just because we're
I need a minute I need a break to be
myself yes to fart and pick my feet and
yeah my wife love her to death but when
we started dating I would go on the road
and I would come back and you know be a
six hour flight and she's like come over
and I'm like I would lie and say my
flight was later just to buy me a couple
hours at the house where I could just
fart be a [__] be a [__] and take a
dump and watch you know a couple of
minutes of YouTube and all that wow yeah
and she's like you don't like me she
took it person I'm like no it's not even
about you it's just me I gotta be a
piece of [__] such a decrepit awful hate
hateful creature yes you need you don't
want to see me like when I'm like this
right like girls like uh they got the
kiwis on their eyes yeah don't look at
me don't look at me I haven't got my
makeup exactly that's our version yes
very [__] good Mark Normand ladies
and gentlemen
what have you got coming up next people
in Australia can they buy tickets buy
tickets we're adding shows like crazy I
go I don't know when this comes out
it'll be out in a week okay great so
I'll be there now tickets are still on
sale going to New Zealand Perth Brisbane
Adelaide uh Sydney you name it and then
you don't say new tour announcement
coming out in August the tickets are on
sale now they're on my website and a new
special in July [__] yeah it's all
happening things are cooking it's all
downhill from here appreciate you man
thank you this was fun what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace